avant de mourir
j'ai envie de vivre
voilà ce que je me suis dit il ya six
ans à cette époque j'avais tout une
carrière prometteuse
un mari adorable brun musclé qui
m'offrait des fleurs une fois par mois
voire deux un appartement ultra équipé
le four à chaleur tournante très
important les tables en bois blanc laqué
l'écran plasma dernier crime j'avais la
vie devant moi et plein de belles
perspectives
je travaillais énormément mais je
m'évade et pendant les vacances dans les
destinations de rêve île maurice
tanzanie seychelles
aix en provence mais j'avais tout mais
il me manquait une chose essentielle
l'harmonie je sentais que cette vie
cadré normes et raisonnée et bien cette
vie n'était pas la mienne et j'ignorais
comment faire pour qu'elle le devienne
et ça se traduisait par un malaise
latent
comme lorsque vous avez ce poids sur les
épaules qui vous pèse et qui pourrait
fournir peuvent finir par vous étouffez
je voulais m'en débarrasser je ne savais
pas comment ça m'a procuré ça m'a pris
plusieurs années avant de trouver la clé
et c'est mon père qui me l'a donnée le
jour où il mourut le 5 mars 2009
derrière ma tristesse mon effondrement
et bien ce jour là je pris conscience
d'une chose la fragilité de la ville je
devais réagir arrêter d'attendre sortir
de ses rails qui ne me convenait pas je
devais reprendre mon destin en main
prendre mon envol vers ce que j'étais
vraiment en exactement deux ans et
quatre mois
j'ai tout quitté ma carrière si
brillante mon mari c'est adorable
bref tout le confort de ma belle
situation sociale
là pour me laisser guider par cette voie
que j'avais ignoré pendant dix années
mon intuition ça peut vous paraître
absurde ou saugrenues de vous fier à
cette intuition mais lorsque mes
oeillères sont tombés que j'ai ouvert
les yeux
le constat était clair ma raison m'avait
poussé à côté de moi même j'étais là où
je ne devais pas être nommé rêves de
voyages d'action d'indépendance j'avais
aspirer à devenir pilote de chasse puis
officier de renseignement pour me
retrouver ensuite capitaine de
gendarmerie à roubaix et enfin aux
fonctionnaires à bercy ce que je voulais
désormais c'était façonné ma vie selon
mon véritable mois celui qui se trouvait
ici et non pas ici et encore moins dans
les mains d'autres personnes c'est
pourquoi j'ai fait le pari
d'expérimenter mon intuition voulait
posséder tous que vous soyez du sexe
féminin ou masculin
et oui messieurs ce que vous appelez
intuition féminine
eh bien ça vous concerne aussi et ouais
et je sens que vos femmes vont être
moins tranquille
non l'intuition vous permet quasi
instantanément de détecter les signaux
négatifs qui annonce un danger pour vous
mais également les signaux positifs qui
indique ce qu'il ya de mieux pour vous
quand j'ai cherché à y accéder
ce fut quelque peu chaotique dans mon
esprit ma raison me criait dans melinda
qu'est ce tu fais tu vas pas tous quitté
continue ta carrière tu vas voir un
prochain parce qu'ils te plaira et puis
lui ton mari as tu vas pas être devant
c'est quand même il va être malheureux
et que vont penser tes proches et une
autre voix me murmurait mais par cette
vie c'est pas toi ça ce à quoi ma raison
répondait mais si tu pars tu vas aller
où
qu'est ce que tu vas faire de ta vie
comment tu vas gagner ta vie je tendait
l'oreille vers mon intuition et
j'entendais ça
le silence c'est bien c'est ce qui
effraie dans le changement de vie le
silence le tableau noir de l'inconnu je
devais me fixer un objectif un cap
j'ai alors commencé l'apprentissage de
quelque chose de nouveau
l' écoute de soi et ça m'a pris du temps
car si mes études m'avait parfaitement
enseigner l'art de raisonner ou démontré
de rues de résoudre des équations
insolvables et bien rien ne
correspondait de près ou de loin à l'art
de s'écouter peu à peu je me suis donc
ouverte à ce que je ressentais à ce qui
me faisait vibrer lorsque vous vous
dites oui et se voir ce fait de revenir
à mes rêves de voyages d'action
d'indépendance j'ai décidé de voyager
seul pendant plusieurs mois je me suis
assise dans mon salon devant une carte
du monde
j'ai fait le vide en moi et j'ai laissé
mon regard me porter vers l'inconnu ça
m'a mené loin très loin jusqu'à
l'extrême orient de la sibérie tout au
nord du kamtchatka ce fut quasi
magnétique mon regard ne pouvait plus
détaché de cette région j'ai su que je
devais aller là bas j'ai commencé à en
parler autour de moi et rapidement un
mot revenait impossible trop loin trop
dangereux trop isolé d'autant plus pour
une femme seule je devais prendre
contact avec des nomades retirer dans la
toundra trouver des financements pour ce
projet apprendre les bases du russe tout
ça en un peu plus de deux mois
si j'avais écouté ma raison je me serais
arrêté là mais j'avais fait le pari
d'expérimenter mon intuition j'ai
persévéré
j'ai mis ma raison au service de mon
intuition
j'ai construit mon projet est gelé
réaliser
au kamtchatka j'ai rejoint dix éleveurs
de rennes les toucs qui nomadisent est
jusque là mer de béring à pied pendant
trois mois sur près de 1000 km nous
allons traverser la toundra franchi les
montagnes sans croiser une seule autre
présence humaine un seul rythme ne
compte est celui de la nature et 7 à ce
rythme que peu à peu les milliers de
pensée qui envahissait mon esprit se
sont évanouis plus j'avançais auprès des
tchouktche plus jeunes imprégnait leur
savoir et plus j'oubliais le mien car
dans ces immensités vous n'avez plus
normes plus d' influence quelconque vous
êtes seul avec vous même vous n'avez
plus qu'à désapprendre pour réapprendre
et enfin être géré appris à regarder et
écouter à déceler le moindre mouvement
le moindre bruissement qui révèlerait un
danger un ours à l'eau un orage
j'ai renouer avec mes sens j'ai retrouvé
la vue l'ouïe l'odorat le goût le
toucher
j'ai ainsi réappris à vivre l'instant
contempler les montagnes regarder les
flammes s'entrelacer ressentir chaque
pas qui se posent dans la toundra
s'arrêter et s'écouter les uns les
autres ou simplement écouter le silence
et ce silence qui quelques années
auparavant m'angoissait et bien ce
silence c'était précisément ce que je
recherchais dans le silence de la nature
j'ai accédé au silence de l'esprit
j'accédais davantage à mon corps à mes
sens et à celle là même qui m'avait
guide et jusque là mon intuition
depuis elle est devenue la meilleure
alliée après le kamtchatka el beïda en
alaska en pologne en indonésie au
kirghizstan dans l'himalaya est
aujourd'hui ici devant vous associer à
la force de ma raison l'intuition m'a
permis de rendre l'impossible possible
et lorsque vous l'écoutez vous n'avez
plus de remords plus de regret car vous
agissez selon ce que vous êtes et
l'intuition vous ouvrent les voix de
l'harmonie
merci